Now through April 2nd.
>> Tucker: IF YOU GREW UP IN
THIS COUNTRY, YOU HEARD THE
STORIES OF THE OLD ROBBER BARONS
FROM THE 19th CENTURY THAT
CRUSHED THE ASPIRATIONS OF
ORDINARY PEOPLE.
ROCKEFELLER, STANDARD OIL,
CARNEGIE.
THE COMPANIES WERE MASSIVE AND
POWERFUL AND AT THE TIME THEY
SEEMED TO BEND THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY TO THEIR WILL.
BUT THAT IS OVER, OR IS IT?
TODAY AMAZON, GOOGLE AND
FACEBOOK AND APPLE ARE NOT JUST
RICHER AND MORE POWERFUL THAN
THE OLD MONOPOLIES THAT HAVE
EXISTED THROUGHOUT HISTORY, THEY
HAVE FAR MORE CONTROL OVER OUR
DAILY LIVES.
WHAT SHOULD WE DO ABOUT IT?
SCOTT GALLOWAY IS HERE WITH US.
HE JUST WROTE A GREAT PIECE OF
ESQUIRE CALLING FOR THE BREAKUP
OF THE TECH TITANS BIGGEST
COMPANIES.
THANKS FOR COMING OUT, SCOTT.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: SO YOU TOOK A LOOK AT
THESE COMPANIES AND THEIR EFFECT
ON THE AMERICAN ECONOMY,
AMERICAN LIFE AND YOUR
CONCLUSION WAS BREAK THEM UP?
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
I THINK WE'RE AT A PART OF THE
ECONOMIC CYCLE, THE ECONOMY
NEEDS TO BE OXYGENATED AGAIN.
I DON'T THINK THEY HAVE DONE
ANYTHING WRONG, IF YOU WILL.
I THINK THE ECONOMY OF
INNOVATION THAT WE HAVE BECOME
DEPENDENT UPON HAS GOTTEN TO A
POINT THAT SMALL COMPANIES HAVE
DIFFICULTY GETTING OUT OF THE
CRIB AND BIG COMPANIES ARE BEING
EUTHANIZED BEFORE THEY SHOULD
BECAUSE THESE COMPANIES CHOKE
OFF CAPITOL.
SO I THINK IT'S TIME.
>> Tucker: WE HAVE A LOT OF LAWS
AGAINST THAT, FEDERAL LAWS.
SO GOOGLE, FOR EXAMPLE, WHICH
HAS A CHOKE HOLD ON HUMAN
INFORMATION, EVERYTHING YOU KNOW
IS ON GOOGLE AND THEY HAVE AN
EFFECTIVE MONOPOLY ON SEARCH.
THAT SEEMS LIKE TOO MUCH POWER
FOR ANY ORGANIZATION TO HAVE.
THEY HAVE TO MISUSE IT.
WHY HASN'T CONGRESS DONE
ANYTHING TO REDUCE THAT POWER
AND THE THREAT TO US?
>> THAT'S THE CORRECT QUESTION.
GOOGLE.
92% OF THE MARKET THAT IS BIGGER
THAN THE ENTIRE ADVERTISING
MARKET OF ANY NATION WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF THE U.S. AND
PROBABLY BLOW BY THE AD MARKET
OF THE U.S. IN TWO YEARS.
BASICALLY BECAUSE CURRENT
ANTITRUST LAW IS BASED ON THE
PREMISE THAT IF IT'S GOOD FOR
THE CONSUMER, IT'S GOOD FOR
SOCIETY.
MOST PEOPLE WOULD HAVE A
DIFFICULT TIME ARGUING THAT
GOOGLE ISN'T GOOD FOR THE
CONSUMER.
THE PROBLEM IS WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT WE DON'T KNOW.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT COMPANIES
WOULD HAVE EMERGED IF WE DON'T
HAVE A DEW
HAVE A DE
HAVE A DUO
HAVE A DUOPO
HAVE A DUOPOLY
HAVE A DUOPOLY.
IF YOU DIDN'T WORK FOR ONE OF
THE TWO, YOU JOINED MAGAZINE AND
NEWSPAPERS AND YOU'RE IN A BIG
THAT IS IN STRUCTURAL DECLINE.
>> Tucker: SO BETWEEN FACEBOOK
AND GOOGLE, ALL DIGITAL NEWS IS
REALLY CONTROLLED, THE PURSE
STRINGS ARE CONTROLLED BY TWO
COMPANIES.
THAT'S NOT A THREATENING
CONCENTRATION OF POWER?
>> I BELIEVE IT IS A THREATENING
CONCENTRATION OF POWER.
IF FOX OR NEWS CORPS THAT WERE
WEAPONIZED BY THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT, THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN
ABANDONED.
IN THE CASE OF FACEBOOK, YOU
HAVE TWO COMPANIES THAT CONTROL
ALMOST ALL TRAFFIC AND
E-COMMERCE AND YOUR PRESENCE ON
THE WEB.
AND ADVERTISERS HAVE NO CHOICE.
SO THERE'S TOO MUCH POWER IN THE
HANDS OF THESE COMPANIES.
I DON'T THINK THEY'RE EVIL.
I DON'T THINK THEY HAVE DONE
ANYTHING WRONG.
I THINK THEY DO WHAT COMPANIES
ARE SUPPOSED TO DO THEY'RE
GROWING EARNINGS.
BUT AT SOME POINT REFEREES NEED
TO STEP IN, THROW A YELLOW FLAG.
THEY WOULD BE BETTER FOR THE
ECONOMY IF THERE WERE 11 OR 12
COMPANIES INSTEAD OF THE FOUR
WE'RE DISCUSSING TODAY.
>> Tucker: I DON'T THINK THERE'S
A SERIOUS CONVERSATION ABOUT